Jean-Pierre Raffarin est avec nous pour
ce premier prof par 3 de l'entre-deux
tours des élections municipales bonsoir
bonsoir merci d'être ici avec nous
demain nous recevrons le ministre chargé
des Relations avec le Parlement Alain
vidalys et donc pour ce rendez-vous
Public Sénat Agence France Presse
Dailymotion et avec mes concerts Nadège
puljack de l'AFP et puis père internaute
Sénat vous êtes bien entouré nous sommes
bien entourés quelle chance nous avons
Jean-Pierre Raffarin comme premier
ministre vous avez connu les revers des
élections intermédiaires comme l’ont dit
pour vous les régionales de 2004 donc on
a très envie de connaître ce que vous
prenez aujourd'hui même si le PS est
super bien sûr toujours dimanche
atténué pour le moins la gifle
électorale subit lors du premier tour
comme responsable de l'opposition vous
promenez ceux de vos amis qui voient
l'UMP renaître ne vous y trompez pas ce
n'est pas qu'il nouvelle c'est qu'ils ne
veulent plus la gauche avez-vous déclaré
vous avez l'occasion très bien informé
absolument vous l'avez dit euh dans
l'enceinte du bureau politique de l'UMP
vous y reviendrez dans un instant et on
va parler d'abord de l'issue qui peut
s'offrir selon vous à François Hollande
que peut-il ou que doit-il faire selon
vous alors qu'on annonce sa prise de
parole à l'issue du second tour
il faut qu'il parle et qu'il parle vite
parce que au fond les Français sont dans
une situation de grande inquiétude notre
situation économique et sociale et d'une
extrême gravité et ces élections
expriment la déception le
désenchantement et il demande un
changement politique et le président
doit annoncer ce changement de ligne
politique et les français demandent à ce
qu'on s'occupe du chômage à ce qu'on
s'occupe des impôts pour les baisser à
ce qu'on s'occupe de la délinquance pour
la limiter et au total on voit que le
gouvernement a l'air intéressé par
d'autres affaires d'autres sujets que
les sujets essentiels des Français donc
le président va devoir parler va devoir
rassurer parce que s'il ne mesure pas
que les Français attendent une nouvelle
orientation ça ne fera que s'aggraver
l'orientation apparemment tout est déjà
bien tracé Jean-Pierre Raffarin on a
l'impression que l'agenda est fixé pour
l'après municipale il y a le pacte de
responsabilité et puis le avec les 50
milliards d'économies exigés par
Bruxelles en fait on peut pas dévier de
cela on nous en parle depuis des mois
passage à l'acte le problème aujourd'hui
avec ce gouvernement c'est qu'on manque
d'action le 14 janvier dans sa
conférence de presse le président de la
République a dit des choses plutôt
raisonnables il y a une politique de
l'offre et de l'autre mais trois mois
et donc comment voulez-vous que les
Français puissent être satisfait de
cette situation de quelqu'un qui a un
moment dit pendant deux ans j'ai pas
fait une très bonne politique je la
change et puis rien ne se passe
déception et puis dimanche soir un
Premier ministre qui était malentendants
et on voit visiblement il n'écoutait pas
les français on a un gouvernement mal
gouvernant malentendant qui au fond
n'écoute pas et donc les Français vont
se dire dimanche prochain on remet la
côte qu'est-ce que vous auriez voulu
qu'il dise jean-marcao qu'il se fasse un
rak-kiri dès le soir du premier tour qui
disent au moins qu'il a entendu le
message du ras-le-bol des Françaises et
des Français sur le fait que personne
n'a l'air de s'intéresser aux problèmes
numéro un quel chômage il a évoqué les
impatients et il aurait dû parler des
colères mais je pense qu'il aurait dû
être plus branché vous savez ce que j'en
dis moi c'est à lui de choisir parce que
si les sanctionné dimanche prochain ma
foi ce sera son problème c'est pas le
nôtre nous dans l'opposition on constate
les choses c'est que aujourd'hui il y a
dans le pays une grande volonté que les
socialistes arrêtent leur politique
échangent est-ce qu'il faut donc d'abord
changer de Premier ministre ça ça
regarde le Président il faut changer il
faut une nouvelle politique et donc
c'est au présent de choisir nos
politiques nouvelle personnalité pour
l'incarner une manière générale mais ça
c'est une responsabilité présidentielle
c'est pas l'opposition de décider cela
donc nous nous disons nouveaux caps et
probablement qu'il faut un nouveau
Premier ministre pour incarner ce
nouveau cas mais ça c'est la
responsabilité de l'expérience je le
disais toujours
au chef de l'État dans toutes les
circonstances similaires c'est d'user
user le Premier ministre jusqu'au bout
c'est une opportunité encore valable
pour vous selon vous aujourd'hui je
pense que par rapport aux situations que
j'ai pu connaître nous sommes dans une
aujourd'hui dans une situation de plus
grande gravité
aujourd'hui il y a une forme de
désespérance dans le pays on a des
problèmes sociaux qui sont majeurs on a
une immigration malmetrisée avec des
problèmes dans un grand nombre de
quartiers aujourd'hui qui inquiètent les
Français on a une situation d'impôts qui
a écrasé la classe moyenne et on a une
situation de chômage qui n'est toujours
pas inversée ça fait deux ans que le
Président de la République s'est engagé
sur cette inversion de la courbe du
chômage et rien ne bouge donc les
Français sont déçus demande une nouvelle
politique sans doute qu'il faudra
incarner cette nouvelle politique c'est
au président de la République de le dire
mais s'il ne mesure pas s'il n'entendent
pas que la colère gronde et que la
colère peut un jour se transformer en
révolte si on ne la comprend pas je
pense que vraiment il y a la situation
dans ce gouvernement qui est une
citation de malentendants
à la haie au sommet international les
grandes puissances c'est une il faut
quand même autre chose qu'un changement
de programme va falloir travailler
pour réfléchir après quelques heures
pleines
nationales je pense que tout ceci est
révolte révèle une certaine
à mon avis une certaine fièvre une
certaine inquiétude dans la République
aujourd'hui je vois qu'un certain nombre
de ministres sont très nerveux donc il y
a de la nervosité dans l'air je pense
que il faut être serein calme et
responsable ce que les Français c'est
une autre politique que ils ne veulent
pas qu'on les qu'on abandonne les
problèmes économiques et sociaux pour se
diviser les Français sur les problèmes
sociétaux ils ne veulent pas qu'on
ressorte comme programme
l'anti-sarkozyme ça fait deux ans que
l'affaire du cas de Nicolas Sarkozy a
été réglé par les Français par une
élection qu'on refasse aujourd'hui de
l'anti-sarkozyme comme un thème de
campagne les Français ne souhaitent pas
ce genre de choses ils veulent qu'on
leur parle emploi sécurité et sur les
sujets importants
une nouvelle politique à Matignon on a
beaucoup évoqué Manuel Valls Claude
bartholon et candidat quasiment déclaré
en évoque également le retour de Laurent
Fabius écoutez cette franchement c'est
pas l'opposition de faire le casting
moi je pense que il est clair que ce
gouvernement manque d'expérience donc
plus on prendra quelqu'un d'expérimenter
plus le président aura des sécurités
donc ça c'est c'est le point important
le président a besoin de sécurité
j'imagine que le Président de la
République aujourd'hui se sent dans une
sorte de climat d'insécurité vis-à-vis
de son gouvernement et donc il a besoin
d'expérience de solidité sans doute
moins de ministres sans doute plus de
cohérence et sans doute une incarnation
du d'un discours politique générale
nouveau qui met l'emploi au cœur des
stratégies c'est à dire une politique
qui parle aux entreprises qui remet de
la confiance dans l'économie parce que
sans confiance il y aura pas
d'investissement il y aura pas d'emploi
donc aujourd'hui ce que doit faire un
nouveau gouvernement c'est créer la
relation de confiance avec les
entreprises qu'on arrête de désigner les
entreprises comme des adversaires que la
finance c'est l'ennemi et que de un
certain nombre de discours qui ont été
tenus contre l'économie tout ceci est
assez désespérant il faut redonner
confiance à nos acteurs économiques
c'est ça l'enjeu alors le mais le gaz de
l'expérience aujourd'hui apparemment
j'ai cité ce serait Laurent Fabius vous
seriez surpris de le voir revenir à
Matignon je parle après je ne serai pas
surpris il a la dimension c'est
quelqu'un de respecter donc c'est
quelqu'un de respectable donc c'est
quelqu'un qui fait ses preuves
aujourd'hui ok donc
sa carrière a fait un certain nombre de
preuves donc ce sont pas des des gens ce
type de profil sont pas des profils ni
légers
là on n'a pas encore vu vraiment de
résultats on n'a pas encore vu vraiment
une puissance à l'action on a vu un
talent de communication on n'a pas
encore vu l'épreuve de l'action donc ça
c'est au président de la République de
gérer ses Paris il y a des moments il y
a des moments où il y a des moments où
le président de la République peut faire
des paris j'ai le sentiment maintenant
qu'il est plutôt un peu dos au mur et
qu'il ferait mieux de ne pas faire trop
de Paris et de jouer la sécurité parce
que la situation du pays est
extraordinairement instable et je vous
assure que dans ces élections
municipales je n'en reviens pas on a vu
moi de chez moi un député battu un
député supplérant battu à notre député
qui gagnait d'habitude au premier tour
qu'avec 20 points de retard par rapport
à la dernière fois donc il y a un
mécontentement très important et donc y
compris dans la majorité il y a un vrai
blues chez les socialistes alors je
pense que fini les aventures maintenant
de la sécurité les gens d'expérience et
de compétences pour mettre en œuvre une
politique qui a été défini comme une
politique de l'offre c'est-à-dire une
politique de l'investissement et de
l'emploi ne vous sentez pas un peu en
solidarité avec Jean-Marc Ayrault vous
savez ce que c'est le premier ministre
bouc émissaire ça y est là les coûts
je pense qu'il n'a pas il n'a pas tous
les tort le Premier ministre c'est une
organisation qui est naturellement
concerne aussi les tâches du dessus le
président de la République et les tâches
du dessous les ministres donc le premier
ministre n'est pas le seul en cause
naturellement mais lui-même quand il
était dans l'opposition était
suffisamment sévère pour qu'on se
permette quelques libertés à son
égards
donc ça cela dit je respecte la personne
et il est engagé à fond dans une tâche
qui est extrêmement difficile je crois
qu'il a pas l'équipe qu'il souhaitait
avoir et qu'il n'a pas forcément les
gens sur lesquels il peut s'appuyer
comme il le souhaiterait et puis aussi
sans doute que les orientations ont été
pas suffisamment clair ce pacte de
responsabilité c'est il y a tout
là-dedans le 14 janvier c'est plutôt
bien accueilli c'est plutôt une
orientation
il faut aussi que le président se remet
lui-même peut plus de décision et moins
de concertation je pense que quand il y
a de l'indécision au sommet on peut pas
demander ensuite à toutes les équipes
d'être au top de leur performances donc
je pense que l'exécutif c'est un
ensemble on voit bien qu'aujourd'hui ça
ne marche pas
Valéry Giscard d'Estaing avait dit ça à
propos après quelques mois de Mitterrand
le socialisme ça ne marche pas et bien
il faut que le Président de la
République puisse se dire que le
socialisme a ne marche pas et donc il
faut faire autre chose aujourd'hui
est-ce que vous voyez François Hollande
toujours en piste pour 2017
le président de la République dans son
camp est toujours en piste la fonction
présidentielle de la Cinquième
République fait que c'est une fonction
très forte moi je ne crois pas que
quelqu'un puisse candidat contre un
président sortant et quand on m'avait
dit en 97 après la dissolution que
Jacques Chirac ne serait pas le de 2002
je souriais parce que j'étais persuadé
que si Jacques Chirac voulait il serait
le candidat parce que la fonction
présidentielle s'impose dans la
cinquième république donc à mon avis il
n'y a pas de place dans le camp du
président contre le président mais donc
à mon avis il sera candidat sera-t-il
élu ça ça dépendra ça dépendra des
circonstances mais nous sommes très loin
des choses ne peuvent se passer beaucoup
de choses et David gérées par le Front
national ça vous inquiète Jean-Pierre
Raffarin ce qui m'inquiète un peu c'est
toute cette campagne sur cette semaine
sur le la place de calfond national
dimanche il y a eu des élus savez-vous
combien il y a eu d'élus du Front
national 500 500 combien il y a eu
d'élus du modèle 600 combien d'élus de
l'UMP 80
000 donc on a 500 élus du Front National
et on a 80000 élus du MP et on fait des
Front national la question qui domine le
tout c'est la troisième force politique
aujourd'hui Jean-Pierre Farah elle sera
la première aux élections européennes au
mois de juin c'est pas sûr du tout je ne
le crois pas et en tout cas si elle est
la troisième force c'est en grande
partie à cause du socialisme les mêmes
très souvent la deuxième force parce
qu'elle est devant les socialistes et on
l'a vu dans des élections législatives
ou le socialisme est exilé par le Front
national c'est-à-dire le scénario de
Monsieur Jospin en 2002 qui n'a même pas
accès au second tour je note quand même
qu'il y a une corrélation entre les
échecs du socialisme et la montée du
Front National et donc certes le Front
National est un sujet grave certes c'est
important de faire en sorte que on
limite son influence dans le pays mais
d'autre part en faire le sujet majeur de
la vie politique française non le sujet
majeur aujourd'hui il faut pas croire
que les gens ont pour le Front national
une attirance extraordinaire ce que vous
disiez tout à l'heure pour lui MP c'est
vrai pour le Front national les gens ont
voté d'abord contre le PS en
sanctions
vous avez très bonne référence donc les
gens ont voté contre le PS tu es
quelquefois il vote contre le PS avec
avec une extrême colère il va de front
il va contre le PS avec plus de
modération il va tu MP mais au fond il
va le voter contre le PS et
l'information du pays aujourd'hui c'est
qu'on a des gouvernants qui sont rejetés
et c'est ça la gravité on a une
situation sociale grave et un
gouvernement faible c'est ça le pays en
marge de du Front national à Marseille
Jean-Claude Gaudin a créé la surprise il
est parti manifestement pour un
quatrième mandat mais il a quand même
passé un accord avec une candidate
guériniste c'est qui s'appelle Lisette
Narducci dans un secteur qui était
détenu par Monsieur Guérini et là
justement le Front national dit ben
voilà
l'alliance contre contre nature
a eu fait la surprise il a fait la
surprise pour des observateurs qui ne
connaissent pas Jean-Claude Gaudin et
donc quand moi j'ai vu qu'on attaque et
Jean-Claude Gaudin sur son âge je me
suis dit ils vont réveiller le lion
c'est un lion qui se battent c'est un
fauve qui aime sa ville qui a fait
beaucoup de choses pour sa ville et
s'est engagé dans cette campagne avec
harder quand vous pensez qu'il y a des
sondages il y a des commentateurs
politiques qui avaient pas seulement il
y avait des commentateurs qui donnaient
la ministre dans le dans
l'arrondissement de Monsieur Gilles côte
à côte et là il a des plusieurs plus
d'une dizaine de fois d'avance et donc
on est dans une situation où il y a
beaucoup de décalages entre
l'observation et la réalité la réalité
c'est que Godin est fort à Marseille
qu'il a beaucoup travaillé à Marseille
et ça se voit dans les urines il arrive
à assigner un accord avec une guériniste
je ne sais pas si ce que vous dites je
n'ai pas vu j'ai pas entendu
peut-être je sais pas si c'est exact en
tout cas ce que je peux vous dire c'est
que Jean-Claude Gaudin dans la position
dans laquelle il est il a pas besoin
d'accord la preuve c'est que il est
largement en tête et qui va gagner et
dimanche et qui va gagner qui va être
une belle fête et je pense que les
socialistes sont gravement trompés en
pensant cacher défaites locales par une
victoire qui aurait été la compensation
idéale Marseille et bien ils vont
échouer sur toute la ligne alors ça il
le mérite alors donc vous avez prévenu
lors du bureau politique de l'UMP au
lendemain du premier tour ne vous y
trompez pas ce n'est pas que les
électeurs nouvelle c'est qu'ils ne
veulent plus de la gauche vous l'avez
effectivement souligné il y a un instant
alors elle UMP plus bénéficiaire
finalement que vainqueur jusque là on en
parle avec Nadège puljack de l'ASP qui
nous rejoint juste après c'est les
éléments d'analyse avec Samia de chir
on la disait affaibli par les Scand
finalement pris sa revanche sur la vague
rose de 2008 ni l'affaire bigmalion ni
les soupçons de trafic d’influence qui
pèsent sur Nicolas Sarkozy n'ont fait
fuir son électorat dimanche au premier
tour des municipales la droite a
récolter plus de 46% des voix objectif
atteint pour le parti de Jean-François
Copé lui-même réélu dès le premier tour
dans sa ville de Meaux l'UMP et le
premier lieu le premier réceptacle de ce
vote sanction grâce au travail de
reconstruction entrepris par notre
famille politique depuis deux ans une
victoire grâce aussi et surtout à la
colère et l'abstention des électeurs de
gauche la victoire de l'UMP me paraît
très nette même si elle se fait
largement par défaut elle tient à la
sure-abstention des électeurs de gauche
elle tient à l'affaiblissement prononcé
parfois spectaculaire comme à Quimper ou
à Grenoble du Parti socialiste mais
malgré tout elle se traduira par la
conquête de nombreuses villes un lien
Valence qu'en Quimper la gauche pourrait
perdre de nombreuses municipalités mais
à droite on se garde de crier victoire
trop vite il est hors de question de
faire preuve du moins notre rayon
Falisse
il faut au contraire rester très
mobilisé mobiliser carreaux second tour
on annonce plus de 200 triangulaires
avec le Front national une situation qui
profite davantage à la gauche la vraie
inconnue est plutôt le comportement des
électeurs du Front national certains ont
voté au premier tour pour s'opposer au
maximum à la gauche au pouvoir est-ce
que parmi ceux-ci certains se diront
finalement que en maintenant leur vote
il favorise les victoires locales de la
gauche et donc reviennent à l'UMP c'est
possible ce n'est pas du tout certain
pour transformer sa victoire en vague
bleue l'UMP dépend donc largement des
voies du Front national l'autre grand
vainqueur de ce premier tour
voilà Nadège pulja qui est avec nous
donc monsieur Raffarin vous connaissez
votre concert de l'AFP bien sûr vos
questions depuis un certain temps elle
vieillit beaucoup moins vite que moi
mais je vous remercie beaucoup Monsieur
Raffin je vais tâcher d'être à la
hauteur
écoutez on a entendu tout à l'heure
monsieur Copé qui disait l'UMP était le
réceptacle des votes mais vous vous avez
dit aussi comme le rappeler Michel tout
à l'heure attention c'est le PS qui a
perdu autrement dit c'est pas nous qui
avons gagné qu'est-ce que vous avez
voulu dire exactement je pense qu'il
faut pas triomphallisme il faut pas se
tromper sur l'état
on est d'accord ça a été la conclusion
d'un bureau politique on dit très
clairement que nous avons engagé un
travail de reconstruction nous avons
construit ce réceptacle du
mécontentement mais de là ce qu'on nous
confie les responsabilités du pays le
travail n'est pas achevé et donc sur
notre projet sur notre union sur
l'ensemble de notre organisation nous
avons encore du travail à faire et donc
je voulais pas simplement que parce que
ces résultats sont très importants ils
sont plus importants quand il attendait
nous-mêmes on a vu des dizaines et des
dizaines de chefs lieux de cantons
basculer et donc dans la France très
profonde le résultat est encore plus
impressionnant que vu de Paris mais la
France d'en bas vraiment il y a une
vague des amours
que ce que vous imaginiez voilà
exactement et donc dans ce contexte là
je ne voudrais pas que l'UMP considère
que c'est son seul mérite et que
maintenant ça y est un petit peu sévère
je pense que dans le jugement des
Français il y a un certain nombre de
choses qui nous concernent et que nous
ne sommes pas innocents de la situation
dans laquelle est le pays complètement
il y a il est clair que les socialistes
sont particulièrement maladroits et ont
pris les mauvaises orientations mais je
pense que nous aussi nous devons
améliorer notre gouvernance pour
l'avenir et donc on doit continuer à
travailler continuer à préparer notre
projet pour l'alternance répondre aux
préoccupations des Français nous opposer
certes mais aussi proposer et donc dans
ce travail là je ne voudrais pas qu'on
se satisface de cette victoire en disant
maintenant c'est pour nous parce que ça
ça veut dire que on peut gagner mais
peut-on gouverner le problème
ont demandé justement dans un sondage si
Nicolas Sarkozy ferait mieux que
Monsieur Hollande 55 % des Français ont
dit oui je pense que on ferait on ferait
beaucoup mieux parce que je pense que la
politique par exemple le fait qu'ils
aient supprimé la TVA anti de
délocalisation le fait qu'ils aient
supprimé le non remplacement d'un
fonctionnaire sur de le fait qu'ils
aient remis en cause la défiscalisation
des heures supplémentaires
tout ceci pénalise l'emploi donc je
pense qu'on aurait fait les confrères
beaucoup mieux néanmoins il faut bien
écouter l'opinion publique et l'opinion
publique nous dit on vous fait confiance
aujourd'hui pour vous opposer au
socialiste mais on ne vous fait pas
encore confiance forcément pour
gouverner le pays donc on a encore du
travail à faire et vous ne voulez pas en
2017 gagner par défaut si j'ose dire moi
ce que je crois c'est qu'il faut essayer
de gagner pour être capable de gouverner
donc c'est pour ça que je suis d'accord
avec ce cas proposé est Copé l'UMP
général c'est-à-dire de faire des
ordonnances ce qui n'est pas fait dans
la première année n'est pas fait après
donc il faut qu'on prépare maintenant
nos propositions
faire connaître aux Français et leur
dire clairement ce que nous ferons dans
les six mois qui viennent et ce que nous
voulons changer c'est comme ça qu'on va
gagner en crédibilité donc la situation
est une extrême gravité je suis heureux
de voir que dans ma famille politique on
n'a pas triomphé même si évidemment on a
été heureux de voir un grand nombre de
villes basculer et Monsieur dans votre
famille politique qui disent des choses
curieuses par exemple Pierre Guillaume
Pelletier a dit que le FN et le PS se
valait vous êtes d'accord avec ça enfin
qu'est-ce que vous en pensez monsieur
bustro vous avez vu à faire une suite
pour dire mais qu'il se taisent est-ce
que vous lui aussi vous lui demandez de
se taire non parce que je pense que dans
un parti politique libre comme le nôtre
il faut que chacun puisse s'exprimer et
donc je pense qu'on n'est pas d'accord
sur le sujet moi je ne mets pas le FN et
le PS sur le même plan mais je mets pas
non plus l'élection présidentielle et
l'élection locale sur le même plan et
donc il faut il faut un peu de nuance là
ce qui est évident c'est que le PS par
ses échecs développe le Front national
donc nous aussi on fait ce que les Front
national appelle l'UMPS c'est-à-dire si
on donne le sentiment qu'on a avec le PS
des sympathies naturellement développe
le Front national donc ce front
républicain c'est une machine à produire
du Front national donc le on peut pas
adhérer à cette logique là
de son nom
il a dit
oui de fréjustement alors il a dit
justement qu'il fallait au contraire un
front républicain et que le Nini ni PS
ni Front national prenait par l'UMP par
Monsieur Copé par vous-même ben c'était
pas la bonne politique il pour empêcher
un maire FN d'arriver à Fréjus il
fallait faire ce front républicain
qu'est-ce que vous en pensez moi je
respecte beaucoup François Léotard
François Léotard a défendu cette thèse
depuis le début moi je pense que sur des
élections municipales il faut une
attitude avec un discernement plus grand
je pense je pense que il faut être
attentif naturellement comportement des
gens alors déclaration et leurs
attitudes mais sur le fond des choses
toute complicité avec le PS de la part
de l'UMP conduit au développement du
Front National et moi je veux lutter
contre le développement du Front
national le Front National est un
adversaire il veut prendre notre place
donc on peut pas être avec lui en
situation de tendresse on est évidemment
en situation d'opposition radicale avec
le Front national mais on n'est pas là
pour l'aider à se développer
vous dire vous êtes en opposition avec
tant d'opposition avec le Front national
on a on a on a vraiment avec le Front
national une adversité qui est une
adversité
de l'empêcher d'accéder à une mairie
vous n'obtez pas pour ce choix en vous
retirant en 3e position on a décidé de
ne pas le faire parce que on a décidé de
ne pas le faire parce que tout ce qui
tous ceux qui affiche une complicité
avec le PS favorise le Front national
aujourd'hui la question des français
contrairement à ce que j'entends partout
aujourd'hui la question des Français
c'est pas le Front national la question
des Français c'est est-ce que le
gouvernement est capable de régler les
problèmes de la France et donc très
souvent on vote ici UMP là-bas Front
national parce qu'on veut d'abord dit
non au Parti socialiste donc la question
aujourd'hui c'est est-ce que le Parti
socialiste est capable de changer de
politique et donc on fait du Front
national un phénomène exceptionnel je
regrette d'ailleurs que à l'étranger
c'est ce qui apparaît aujourd'hui je
vous rappelle 500 élus Front national 80
000 élus UMP donc gardons les
proportions ce qui compte aujourd'hui
des chiffres très importants et il est
évident aujourd'hui que la question qui
est posée à la France c'est la question
de son redressement économique c'est pas
d'autres questions et tous les autres
problèmes sont la conséquence de notre
situation
d'économie extrêmement fragile donc le
Front national c'est un adversaire pas
d'alliance mais non plus pas d'alliance
avec le Parti socialiste qui est
responsable de cette situation
c'est de Monsieur Copé à propos des
dépenses de campagne de 2012 et même il
rêvait d'obtenir sa tête je crois qu'on
peut dire des choses comme cela et si le
succès de l'UMP se confirme dimanche
tout ça tombe à l'eau il y a pas il est
pas question de faire son procès les pas
question de se mettre autour d'une table
pour lui demander des comptes l'UMP pas
plus que la presse plus que les
observateurs ne sont des juges et des
magistrats l'affaire est devant la
justice elle est posée de réussite que
la justice à son travail et d'ici là on
n'a pas à transformer les hommes
politiques en magistrat donc la question
sera posée de savoir si nos dirigeants
dans leur ensemble sont à la hauteur de
leur tâche si on gagne les élections la
réponse est plutôt oui donc nous verrons
un peu comment les choses se présentent
mais en tout cas ce n'est pas à nous de
faire le travail des magistrats la
justice est saisie qu'elle puisse faire
son travail normalement alors Nicolas
Sarkozy a publié une lettre
retentissante vendredi dernier dans le
Figaro vous n'avez pensé quoi de cette
lettre très franchement au départ
j'étais un peu surpris parce que je l'ai
trouvé naturellement prenante et je l'ai
vu comme quelque chose qui était
profonde sa part et j'ai vu que à deux
jours du scrutin c'était quelque chose
qui va surpris je note que des électeurs
de droite qui l'ont lu ont trouvé cette
lettre éclatante de vérité ils ont
trouvé cette lettre positive et donc
d'évidence est une lettre qui a
participé à la mobilisation de
l'électoratisation justement je pense
que les attaques ont été victimes
Nicolas Sarkozy avait créé une
inquiétude et les sympathisants de
Nicolas Sarkozy qui ne sont pas toutes
l'opposition mais qui sont une partie de
l'opposition sont inquiets quand ils ne
voient pas Nicolas Sarkozy est combatif
retrouvez le Sarkozy combatif ça les a
rassuré et donc je pense que c'est un
élément important mais le son de
l'affaire c'est les socialistes en
empathie parce que quand on voit que les
socialistes ressortent l'anti-sarkozy
alors que ça fait deux ans qui devrait
être passé à autre chose tu devrais nous
parler d'emploi qui ne devrait parler de
stratégie et qui ressortent Sarkozy
parce qu'ils n'ont pas d'autres discours
que l'anti-sarkozy le total de tout ça
sexe sanction contre le PS parce que
l'UMP devra ressortir Nicolas Sarkozy
est-ce que pour vous c'est le seul
rempart face à Marine Le Pen à la
prochaine présidentielle nous avons il y
a beaucoup trop tôt pour le dire il est
beaucoup trop tôt pour le dire nous
avons plusieurs personnalités qui ont la
dimension pour assumer les
responsabilités d'état-majeur je pense
je pense à la
Juppé je pense à naturellement à
François Fillon je pense à Nicolas
Sarkozy et a beaucoup d'autres et donc
tout cela le moment venu on a un
dispositif de primaire nous verrons
comment les choses se présentent donc
nous choisirons le moment venu mais il
est évident que la place de Nicolas
Sarri est singulière puisque lui a déjà
fait la preuve qu'il était capable de
gouverner donc il a déjà montré sa
propre capacité et d'une certaine
manière la légitimité de son ambition si
ambition il y a donc
si semble-t-il j'ai aussi cette
intuition là mais nous verrons bien là
tout à l'heure pour le remplacement de
Jean-Marc air on verra là Alain Juppé il
est porté vers 2017 après sa victoire à
Bordeaux je pense que
l'inexpérience est parfois
l'incompétence que l'on trouve dans les
sphères du pouvoir aujourd'hui en effet
appel expérience et compétences
qu'est-ce qu'ils sont deux atouts
ça peut être finalement ça peut même
être d'autres et donc ça dépendra le
moment venu comment les choses se
présentent nous verrons ça le moment
venu
dans un restaurant
elle est pas en question mon ambition
mais en tout cas ce que je peux vous
dire c'est que la présidentielle quand
je vous ai dit tout à l'heure qu'il
fallait pas se réjouir trop tôt il faut
se dire que c'est une élection très
satisfaisante il faut encourager les
Français à repasser une deuxième couche
dimanche prochain parce que on a un
gouvernement de malentendant et donc il
faut continuer
il va falloir parce que là ils ont
besoin
mais qui n'a peut-être pas l'énergie de
l'efficacité donc ça c'est un vieux
débat de la démocratie déjà Platon ou
parler de cela et donc il y a des c'est
très très vieux comme comme question je
pense que néanmoins il nous faut faire
en sorte que la valeur de l'éthique soit
au premier rang des valeurs politiques
merci Nadège Perrine Arnaud arrive donc
maintenant Jean-Pierre Raffin pourrait
évoquer vos ambitions personnelles on va
parler de la présidence du Sénat des
élections régionales qui sait à nouveau
face à Ségolène Royal Sandra sirquera
il fut l'un des premiers à revendiquer
le droit d'inventaire des années Sarkozy
il a aussi affirmé que l'UMP n'est pas
apte à gouverner une liberté de parole
que Jean-Pierre Raffarin cultive
volontairement c'est quelqu'un qui a une
forme de bonhomie et qu'en même temps
qu'il y a beaucoup de chance politique
et qui a un profil très modéré et se
nomme de rassemblement il y a une forme
de gourmandise chez lui à apparaître
comme l'éternel empêcheur de penser en
rond le sénateur n'a pas renoncé à jouer
sa partition à l'UMP et se positionne
même comme un sage au sein de son parti
en mal de leadership souvent le premier
ministre effectivement et à son apogée
puis quelques années après
il est passé Jean-Pierre Raffarin non
seulement un homme actif et il a un
avenir politique probablement s'il le
souhaite la seule question que l'on peut
se poser c'est quelle est la volonté de
Jean-Pierre Raffarin d'imprimer un
rythme et d'avoir une ambition alors
quel avenir pour Jean-Pierre Raffarin
va-t-il continuer à jouer l’éternel
médiateur à droite tentera-t-il de
rester au centre du jeu dans la
perspective de 2017 ou plus probable
envisage-t-il de récupérer le poids
touchant
président de la Région ne résisterait
pas à l'idée d'affronter Ségolène Royal
en 2015 le reconquère des régions
l'année prochaine il y a 22 régions il y
en a qu'une qui est gérée et bien gérée
par l'UMP donc si Jean-Pierre Raffarin
peut nous reprendre
la présidence de la région
Poitou-Charentes bravo à moins que
Jean-Pierre Raffarin ne rêve toujours de
présider le Sénat et de rejouer le duel
de 2008 avec Gérard Larcher qui est déjà
candidat en octobre prochain une autre
bataille au goût de revanche
alors on vous voit donc en différents
endroits vous allez pouvoir nous dire
à faire un bonsoir
j'espère que mon écoule mon épouse n'a
pas regardé cette émission parce qu'elle
va s'inquiéter de mes ambitions
de la droite c'est guise après ce
premier tour des élections municipales
parce qu'on peut rappeler quand même que
les grands électeurs dessinateurs ce
sont les mers et les élus municipaux
vous y croyez au basculement du Sénat à
droite en 2014
je suis sûr de la victoire en 2017 14
2017 nous gagnerons parce que la
génération de ces municipales va faire
deux générations de sénateurs donc 2017
c'est gagné maintenant déjà du premier
tour 2014 ça reste un certain on verra
dimanche ça reste un certain puisque les
socialistes on devient possible alors
que vous étiez plus négatif il y a
quelques semaines encore il faut
attendre un certain nombre de grandes
villes qui par exemple si on gagne Brive
on change des choses si on gagne
Angoulême les choses donc ce stand des
départements pour lesquels qui sont
renouvelables et pour lesquelles on
n'avait pas d'espoir très fort et que
maintenant on peut avoir des espoirs
donc on verra ce qu'il faudra à le
moment venu c'est qu'on on est une
stratégie au fond pour sauver le Sénat
pour rénover le Sénat pour changer le
Sénat et mais bien sûr on voit bien que
le Sénat est en cause aujourd'hui le
gouvernement le marginalisme on a on a
le sentiment qu'il y a une forme
d'absence mais oui mais ça c'est pas
notre fête c'est parce que il y a eu un
partage du pouvoir qui n'a pas
correspondu à un partage du projet et
donc un certain nombre de groupes
politiques les écologistes des
communistes ont participé au partage du
pouvoir mais que le moment venu quand il
y a un texte à voter ne vote pas donc
partage du pouvoir sans partage du
projet il y a le clash et au fond il y a
cette forme d'impuissance et au fond les
socialistes n'ont jamais eu pour le
Sénat une considération extrêmement
puissante on se souvient des
déclarations de Monsieur Jospin donc on
a besoin d'un bicamérisme en France on a
besoin d'avoir une assemblée qui une
assemblée d'une intelligence tempérée
d'une assemblée qui qui puisse modérer
un peu l'Assemblée nationale mais qui
puisse en même temps penser à long terme
on a besoin d'un nouvel élan pour le
Sénat et donc le moment venu il va
falloir travailler sur ce projet il
s'agit pas de prendre la place des
socialistes il s'agit vraiment d'avoir
une autre vision une autre ambition une
autre force pour le Sénat on pense à
vous tient à cœur et vous avez envie de
sortir ce projet Jean-Pierre
puisque Jean-Pierre Bel a annoncé qu'il
ne serait pas candidat renouvellement de
son mandat vous avez été surpris par son
entrée j'étais surpris c'est quelqu'un
pour qui j'ai de l'estime j'étais
surpris je m'attendais pas à cette
décision je ne sais pas je ne sais pas
c'est peut-être personnel c'est
peut-être lié à la situation de son
groupe politique tu as des concurrences
internes je n'en sais rien en tout cas
je ne peux pas dire que c'était un
président qui était où désagréable ou
insuffisant il a été un président du
Sénat que je respecte et que j'ai
respecté donc je n'ai pas je ferai
autrement que lui mais il est je crois
très important dans cette maison de
savoir juger aussi les personnes avec
leur vraie qualité et la sienne est
existante votre avenir aussi peut-être
dans la région
ce que vous confirmez que vous aimeriez
bien affronter ces glonens royales aux
élections régionales de 2015 là aussi
pour être très franc c'est pas moi c'est
pas mon ambition tout le monde me prête
ça pourquoi parce que j'ai dit je répète
que je pense que nous allons gagner
massivement les régionales c'est une de
mes déceptions un peu historiques la
région n'est pas un mandats
d'enracinement on a eu 5 élections
86 92 98 la gauche est au pouvoir et la
droite gagne massivement avec ces trois
élections 2004 2010 la droite est au
pouvoir la gauche gagne massivement on
peut danser déjà annoncer une victoire
massive de l'opposition aux élections
régionales c'est pas un mandat
d'enracinement ce sont des mythes et
donc et elle bascule un peu toutes de la
même façon donc quel que soit la
personnalité et d'une certaine manière
plus la personnalité est une
personnalité exposée connue plus la
sanction est forte
gouvernement d'ailleurs elle sera
peut-être pas candidat de régionale
puisqu' je le saurai amené à occuper un
grand ministère
du gouvernement actuellement je pense
que et son intuition d'une part et son
énergie d'autre part ne pourrait qu'être
utile donc elle peut être une des
solutions pour relancer ce gouvernement
c'est peut-être en tout cas elle ne
manque pas de qualité pour cela en tout
cas par rapport au défauts que l'on peut
constater elle aurait des qualités
complémentaires alors vous annoncez la
victoire de de l'opposition
au sénatorial au régional vous avez
juste un doute pour 2017 si je comprends
bien on va bien sûr bien sûr parce que
de toute façon regardons les choses
historiquement ces grosso modo du 48 52
les institutions sont très très fortes
dans la cinquième république moi je me
souviens quand Jacques Chirac perd la
dissolution tout le monde le dise
Jacques Chirac est fini méfiez-vous le
président de la République en France
n'est jamais fini et soyons très
attentif à ça la fonction la Cinquième
République elle donne au président une
force institutionnelle très puissante
donc un président peut toujours un
moment ou un autre bondir notre
président actuel est en situation
d'extrême faiblesse une impopularité
massive ça ne veut pas dire que dans
d'ici trois ans une nouvelle donne une
situation internationale contenue de
l'état de gravité de la société
française il peut se passer des
soubresauts violents brutaux je le
crains je suis très inquiet sur la
situation du pays et donc je ne sais pas
quelle serait la situation à l'issue
d'un certain nombre d'événements dans
notre pays donc je suis d'une extrême
prudence et ce que je sais c'est que la
fonction institutionnelle n'est pas une
fonction légère on va revenir à cette
semaine avec la visite en France du
président chinois une visite très
protocolaire fastueuse dessinée que
finalement la relation franco-chinoise
va bien va mieux que lors du précédent
quinquennat où ça avait été un peu
difficile parfois avec Nicolas Sarkozy
les deux derniers années du Sarkozy les
relations étaient stabilisées il y a eu
une période en 2008 difficile à
l'occasion des Jeux olympiques mais par
la suite notamment pour la préparation
du G20 la relation entre Roger et
Nicolas Sarkozy était une relation de
confiance il s'était l'un et l'autre
apprivoisé le voyage de François
Hollande a plutôt été un succès en Chine
et celui de Jean-Marc Ayrault également
donc la visite que le président français
ne le connaissait pas du tout la Chine
c'était sympa absolument et donc là il a
fait beaucoup d'efforts pour s'installer
dans le paysage institutionnel le
Premier ministre est allé plusieurs
jours
a signé un certain nombre de
partenariats donc ils ont fait des
efforts pour bien montrer une bonne
volonté française et donc le président
chinois rend je dirais la politesse avec
cette visite d'État je crois que vous
savez il y avait plus d'une centaine de
contrat qui était en préparation donc il
a fallu en sélectionner un certain
nombre pour essayer de manière publique
il y a une vraie coopération qui se fait
je pense que la relation entre la Chine
et la France et de bonne qualité je
pense qu'elle est stabilisée aujourd'hui
et donc que on peut avoir confiance dans
ce lien là on sent que effectivement la
France ne veut pas froisser les chinois
au point de desserter totalement la
question des droits de l'homme je ne
suis pas sûr qu'elle soit désertée elle
n'est pas politiquement utilisée mais
elle est pas forcément désertée pendant
cette visite du président chinois elle
est en général toujours abordée mais
naturellement ce que souhaite les
Chinois c'est qu'on les préviennent
qu'on parle avec eux et qu'on en fasse
pas une exploitation politique il ne
souhaite pas que on donne à l'occidental
des leçons occidentales à travers des
médias occidentaux donc ils veulent
qu'on respecte un peu leur diversité et
culturelle du style et donc mais quand
on est face à eux on a des discussions
approfondies j'ai vu des listes de
dissidents qui étaient transmises aux
dirigeants chinois dans le passé il y a
un certain nombre de choses qui se font
je suis sûr que la diplomatie française
continue dans cette voie mais est-ce
qu'on nous a pas fait croire que la
prospérité économique elle est favorisée
la liberté d'expression par exemple en
Chine ce qui n'est pas le cas du tout
vous le savez aujourd'hui il faudrait il
faut nuancer tout ça parce que si vous
regardez bien Twitter enfin le web est
beau moi j'ai un compte Webo en Chine
je vois qu'il y a quand même beaucoup
d'expressions il y a plusieurs centaines
de millions de gens qui sont sur wibo et
certes il y a des messages qui sont
effacés mais les chinois sont très
créatifs pour détourner les procédures
et je pense que la société civile
chinoise est en marche elle bouge et la
jeunesse je vous savez
Twitter est interdit mais je reçois sur
Webo les gens qui me félicitent pour des
messages sur Twitter ça veut dire que
Twitter est interdit mais qui trouve le
moyen souvent d'écouter Twitter donc je
pense que la société civile est très
active et qu'elle s'exprime plus
librement qu'on le dit au fond la
liberté totale si on ne fait pas de
politique c'est ça la règle donc dès
qu'on touche à la politique qui a un
certain nombre de risques mais sur le
fond des choses c'est une société qui
peut s'exprimer de manière très libre
sur bien des sujets voilà pour cette
visite d'État du président chinois je ne
sais pas si je prononce bien c'est très
bien
Poutine vous et moi nous avons des
caractères très semblables ça fait un
peu peur quand même bon il faut se
méfier parce que si ça a été traduit en
russe en chinois va venir en français
mais je pense que c'est pas tout à fait
vrai dans la mesure où le Président
c'est génie a beaucoup de rondeurs à de
l'empirisme a beaucoup de pragmatisme et
qui qu'il a une communication non
verbale assez forte alors que Monsieur
Poutine est assez glacial avec des yeux
au laser donc c'est pas ces deux formes
de personnalité qui me paraissent quand
même différente il y a un côté un peu
plus latin je sais j'ai une ping avec
les mains avec la communication
psychologie ça compte aussi en politique
absolument mais en tout cas
je lui souhaite la bienvenue en France
Merci Merci vous allez suivre cette
visite d'État de très près vous y êtes
même associé bien sûr Jean-Pierre
Raffarin merci d'avoir été avec nous
aujourd'hui demain donc Perrine nous
accueillons à l'invidaliste donc le
ministre chargé des Relations avec le
Parlement à demain très vite